Hello
everyone I
'm from Xbox
[music]
One point 7
peopleagamsion
[music]
Thank
you.
Loot it
[music] I
'll shut it up quickly
My
persona Let's shoot it
[Applause]
[music]
It's fine because it will fly Please
help me beat
him  Give me,
I promise you more than I expected
Please start over again This time I
'm with Cendrillon That
will
[music]
Persona 5 The Royal Released on October 21st
Break it down
with me
Thinking about the future development of the Japan series  At that time,
I started considering a worldview that was not Japan during the Warring States period
.  In addition to a mythology with thousands of years of history
and art unique to the age of the five senses,
we decided that a store centered on Chinese martial arts and a bargaining combat
could be a concept for a new title
.  The policy has started.For
this work, the dark world view
makes it easy to recall powerful enemies and harsh environments
, and I believe that it is an important element to give you a sense of accomplishment when you overcome them.
I wanted to portray it from the front, which is rare even in the world market.
While making use of the know-how and knowledge of Sangokushi, which has been drawn more than ever with clouds,
[ __ ] will create a dark world with Team Ninja's unique production method and
approach.
The battles of this work are characterized by the elegant and speedy action that is characteristic of Chinese martial arts
,
and the tactics in which attacks and defenses are exchanged in the course of the flow.
We are aiming for a sense of coexistence of excitement and excitement.It
is necessary for the player to be satisfied with the operation and the result.
In character creation, I think it's especially important that
the player
can play with the look they want, so they can be more immersed in the game,
and
especially in titles like Orlon, playing
so that their favorite character doesn't die is
also a big
motivation.
Also, in online play, etc.,
there will be a lot of variation in appearance between players, so
I think the game value is also due to this.
For that reason, by
not placing the main character as a specific character
, there are fewer restrictions in terms of situations and productions,
and
I draw
a lot of scenes where the main character plays an active role in spectacular battlefields, such as depicting relationships with various warlords that appear in Romance of the Three Kingdoms.
I think it's an advantage that it's easy [Music] I think it
's not the difficulty itself that makes it popular, but
that the feeling of accomplishment you get when you overcome a difficulty is an emotion that
you can't easily experience in other genres or games
Trial and error  If the process of playing is not unreasonable,
but
has a high degree of freedom and fairness, I feel that it will become
a title that many players will like as an experience that doesn't
cost money.
We're working on policies so that
players can experience
the experience and sense of accomplishment that can only be found in titles.
You can enjoy different play styles,
so please try to
find a play style
that suits you.
The key to your strategy is whether
you dare to challenge a formidable enemy in order to make a big deal, or
whether you go steady and how you suppress the cleansing
[music]
[applause]
Thank you for waiting  Thank you very much for watching the
Tokyo Game Show 2022
xbox stream.
In order for everyone to enjoy this year's show as well, we
have prepared a special prize packed with the latest game footage and content from various titles from Japan's proud game developers and talented studios from around the world, including Asia.  In this year's Xbox
STREAM, we will deliver the latest information including Pal World, a craft game where
you can enjoy survival in an open world,
and a
new map
campaign mode from Nara or Blade Point
.
Near-future battle
Action Exo Primal
We have prepared the latest video for this time Please take a
look
[Music]
[Music] If
this is also a possibility I
'll just blow everyone away
[Music] It's
interesting
I'll show you
The power of the blue
Let's go, we're going to
lose Hurry up and
run, the
opposite sex is good
Young people must be like that
If you get in the way, just
clean it up
Zero,
Eslator Then it's cool I'm going I'm going to take care of me, let's go I'm
born
Let's do our best together
Prepare  Okay
Population's dream is myself
I am the thunder god
Absolute corruption
[music]
[applause]
Digital distribution of the Sky Anniversary Edition will start
today on Xbox One and exbox
series X series S.
By updating the game, you will
be able to access the original again.
For details, please check Best Japan's SNS etc.
Fallout 76's long-awaited new
content, The Pit, has finally begun distribution
. Even those who are new to Fallout 76
can enjoy it,
so
please give it a try.
Lastly, at
last year's Tokyo Game Show, Red
Fall's full Japanese localization was announced.
However,
we have decided to
support in-game
text localization for Chinese and Korean when the simplified characters are opposed.
Please stay tuned
Thank you  Thank you
[music]
Thankyou
Movie I'm going to ask you something important from now on
Salvation
initiative Can you save our world?
I'm traveling through society Oliver I
want to help my mother Go, I guess I've traveled for this purpose
Those who want to save the dying world can change
death and
the fate of destruction
Hey
[music]
If it's something called body strength,
everyone's living in this world to the
fullest
.
Next week, the headmaster of the academy will be
Monokuwa.So, it's
a shopping district for
the relief version of Crazy
Max.What is the
culprit
?
That's why
there are obstacles
along the way That's different Extreme
[music]
will come
[MUSIC]
My clan is the generation
I've protected this town by following the path of tradition
[MUSIC]
I'm going my own way
It's the top
[music]
I'm always running with a grade,
but
[music]
I'm free, but I
'll recuperate This will be later The attack
in the cave has been
opened The
hunt will begin
[music]
If you follow all the rules
The
world does not change It was a new character Kiriko who will be unveiled to the world for the first
time Did you see your partner fox?
Introducing
jrpg100au Den, which we can't wait to release.There
are characters that cost more than 100 yen.You
can enjoy a magnificent story.This is the
first work in 25 years by Yoshitaka Murayama and Junko Kono.
The 100-yen recharge is
available on Game Pass from the first day of release.
Now, let's take a look at
the new 100 Yen Denden game
play video, as well
as the interview video with character designer Junko Kakino and director Osamu Komta
[music]
[applause]
[
Applause] Personally,
I think the most important thing when releasing a new title is to have
people experience something new and interesting that they haven't had before.
The appeal of 100 Yen Densetsu is, of course, the ensemble drama unfolded
by more than 100 heroes drawn by Mr. Moriyama,
and the variety of games such as battles that let players experience the ensemble drama and
town planning for one-on-one battles
.  The characters that appeared in 100 Yen Finite Rising are
only a few of the 100 heroes in
AU.  I think
it will be one of the great pleasures to become friends fighting alongside
Murayama. In the unzukuri dramas drawn by Mr. Murayama
, characters from various standpoints appear, and
each of them acts in their own position,
and the story is spun by intertwining them.
However,
there are also characters who are completely unsuitable for fighting, such as the accessory shop
Scarsh and the armor shop Frida.
By making
them playable, the real pleasure of the game is being able to spotlight them at will
.
I don't think so. I'm currently drawing pictures and putting my soul into each character so that each character has its
own charm
.
[Music] When
I'm making a character, I fall in love with every character,
but recently I
've played Rising, so
CJ and Company E have fallen in love with Lou.
So
, I'm thinking of releasing a character like the character that won the first place in the voting results in the game
.
Regarding the 100 Yen Oil Field this time,
we started with the support of our fans.
I'm really sorry about that,
but
if you send me a message now, please wait a
little longer, so
please wait.
Music]
[applause]
[music]
[music
] epic action-packed  Let's go on a journey and change our destiny This work will be coming to the
game pass soon today
Our battle still
had a continuation And
so much more
To help our friends who have been taken into the company
Pray to the water correctly and follow them  An ancient weapon
that seems to crash into the
world The boys are once again in the world A
harsh fate awaits
and the truth hidden on the other side of the world
Unbearable pain and
the death of a loved one Turns a
boy into an avenger I will
never allow him to be cornered forever
[MUSIC]
You don't know what lies ahead
3000 I've wasted all my troubles,
but
[MUSIC]
Ok Colt Hold on tight
I'm piecing together the clues on this island  I'm
falling on [music] and
I've killed 8 people in 24 hours
.
Hey,
everything seems to be fine today My island My
rules
[music
] See you again
vs.
This is the part of the brain that manages the
Mento system. Hello everyone.
[Music]
Thank you.
Thank you very much for
coming.
Tokyo Game Show 2022 is still
going on. Please continue to enjoy it.
[Music]